okay guys we're going back in this game
is scary as [ __ ] let's see how we do
we just finished prologue so no wait now
[ __ ] now
oh ah respect to what to be patient and
coffee is so important for coffee
everything would fall okay let's do this
I'm waiting for it to load okay I can't
make this go any faster I'm sorry guys
I'm sorry okay my hair is all [ __ ] up
that's all I got to say in fact that's a
little head and shoulders can't fix [ __ ]
happen it's [ __ ] dirty everything said
dirty in this place what the [ __ ] like
the substance give well to say that the
dark vapors rising to ship your lung
pipes as long as I remain examine the of
it that's in there
I'm right here a couple days ago that
wasn't basically prepared I just need to
light it up to ensure my safety at night
wait so why do I need this to be safe
so we're bottle live involves our
staying at a racially protective
substance after nightfall reason uh okay
it's like a vapor or some [ __ ] you know
popular irritates up not guaranteed
safety it's at the pot Monday cast pot
have their shutters since the accident
can to figure out one thing he's musher
but these red pulsating mushrooms so
tasty
okay but what is this bear trap irrigate
this whoa
okay digging this [ __ ] they used to
mushrooms in the household I just sell
it Derek
I really do gonna barricade [ __ ] here
bed lamp is it nighttime can't tell the
hell is that hey the Red Bull City which
is it ain't watch out now rank photo of
a road drug uh duh okay that's scary you
say American where the windows are gonna
stay or should do the same with the
other windows that birdie can that one
is it nighttime I really can't tell Oh
mushrooms
CUC
I have enough no okay well okay say my
as Moses [ __ ] start barricading right
you have zero blanks can it go [ __ ]
yourself work bad I can't make [ __ ]
[ __ ] check its head
there's a well here convert wood logs
the planks container now
that's act it's a pretty tasty I get it
I don't mind I find out
turn on Jenner for dark hiding a showers
do good they were coming either way
holy [ __ ] now
[ __ ] okay man I tell you like this I'm
glad I got a [ __ ] pit ball in the
house I need some [ __ ] wood huh what
the [ __ ]
man under grand entrance with stump hey
if the one thing orders game is don't
[ __ ] and go the entrance unless you have
[ __ ] what's your god tab mushroom can
I eat this cookie ball dude I don't have
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like I don't have a weapon
I said Mao say what is that okay
how about take a mess yeah well what the
[ __ ] is that an app that can run it the
sound in this game is what makes it
[ __ ] scariest [ __ ] burn how says I
hear a [ __ ] dog in here holy [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] dog in here
please do not say my little dog what's
it what is this oh it's a [ __ ] form
here
the [ __ ] is that noise
I'm just trying to get that [ __ ] out of
here no mushrooms poisonous mushrooms no
I guess a harvest at right
how do I know one [ __ ] nightfall is
is anyone now I don't have like [ __ ]
anything
some scariest [ __ ] noise in the scan
this I like it holy [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here
holy [ __ ] okay I guess we shouldn't be
tail for from the house a second sound
going nuts in there [ __ ] scariest
[ __ ] whoa
one just got [ __ ] tanked
hey okay
this is [ __ ] disgusting
all right and let's look at the [ __ ]
path I do not want to get [ __ ]
murdered over here
okay can I build anything
and ademma bandages change rapid now I
need to
now I could build a bunch of change apps
I just kind of want to just drop [ __ ]
off
um what done I really need right now I
don't need this bottle managers do I
need that me I don't really need that
now I'm looking mushroom well now let me
take this here I can cope with it
okay can I use this now guess I can't
use this right now
yeah you just kind of keep putting in
the oven okay that's fine
nail broke and eat all this holy [ __ ]
there's a there's a [ __ ] hole right
here you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
okay okay I gotta [ __ ] make like a
trap right here on
I'd say bandages
yeah and the other [ __ ] advantage I can
get
is it set
[ __ ] they said it
there we go perfect
no okay we gotta keep livin [ __ ]
I got [ __ ] nothing I need [ __ ]
wood badly [ __ ] get wood for him
whereas this way
Jim medow burn house under grand
entrance
[ __ ] yeah there yeah it's [ __ ] scary
that's all I gotta say but what is that
you don't see that huh it's a rabbit
hey baby
okay [ __ ] hear that [ __ ] hey how's that
noise cut that out okay okay
I'm at the burn house holy [ __ ] the guy
that [ __ ] I see of a house [ __ ] I
don't mind if I do yeah baby
all right now am I gonna get murdered oh
[ __ ] they're like fighting well see what
happens [ __ ] happens
check off and get the [ __ ] out
and I guess they made pace with each
other
and here's the point we open the door
you [ __ ] around
there's the check over there
you can't go further without the key
[ __ ] can I get that game sick I can't
check that can i yeah I need a [ __ ]
weapon badly she's like a shovel or some
[ __ ]
well what is that what holy [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] [ __ ]
where am I except me
broken tractor guess it's [ __ ] like
dark right now dude I haven't found it
like [ __ ] I'm not gonna [ __ ] make it
get it what the [ __ ] oh yeah
the [ __ ] is my house
Oh
goddammit
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] reload I get [ __ ]
in the ass that [ __ ] in the ass the
[ __ ] how could I be so dumb before my
Shane trap
oh my god
[ __ ] a that was one of the saddest
things I think I've ever [ __ ] seen oh
my god I cannot believe that happened I
was just [ __ ] helpless I cannot
believe that happened and I guess we're
down this again what did I gather out
there and you got a [ __ ] out there
I made that it's fun so I just don't
have the burn house and that and I
[ __ ] get this container
I need [ __ ] blood oh [ __ ] your
[ __ ] dog out there
and just run straight up here and get
yes that is just gay light structure
I hear people talking yeah I pay someone
off
it's scary in here
up here should be the house [ __ ] I need
a [ __ ] lockpick okay there's locked
another crate is [ __ ] locked wait I
think that is but just [ __ ] in the house
that I was able to get
anything
oh yeah any that I keep telling you that
okay
I'm going on this way this is basically
nightfall
that's nice I've failed
that's lovely okay well what the [ __ ]
everything needs a lockpick
oh there's a body
carry a lockpick now [ __ ] a little more
wire getting [ __ ] dark let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
wait what's nothing a [ __ ] dog right
here somewhere
what is this over medium court [ __ ]
not falling for that [ __ ] again
walking far around here
this is the dorsum
Oh tester
ten by that mushroom that makes anything
else just to make one change for apps
I need somewhere that's just like
[ __ ] two entrances
way too many [ __ ] engines over there
okay put one there
another one now okay I guess they're
just [ __ ] late
[ __ ] push it down it off is that
that wait wait right aye sir head again
broken tray I suppose I had to go west
char meadow sound forest old woods
anything happening that scary
how do I know it's [ __ ] daylight is
that thing yeah there's the noxious gas
see the whole thing covering with gas oh
here's someone
holy [ __ ] this is insane [ __ ] scurry
should I turn off the generator what's
the point of generator he is cuz be
pitch-black otherwise yeah it's [ __ ]
pitch-black holy [ __ ] that's why I need
the generator oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
well what is that what the [ __ ] is that
hey someone just cause a [ __ ] fire
over there Oh like a mushrooms being
born or something what the [ __ ] is that
well there was a store in front the door
so it can't be that door and there's a
chain shop over there so
that's a nice
ma'am ma'am I hear someone walking I
think at the torch
I have [ __ ] chained traps all over
the place [ __ ] I should have dragged
lamp in here
can I be like morning soon right
[ __ ] long last night
there's the mast
stay away from my door please
[ __ ] long last night oh oh well I
guess I should just go [ __ ] myself
jessimae here now
holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ] terrifying
oh yes
holy [ __ ] the doors open you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me
wow I am amazed No
I'm amazed anyone [ __ ] here let [ __ ]
are you go [ __ ] yourself
yeah before I can't I smile you push a
chance you could I don't know update for
carcasses nice smells like what huh so
you got a [ __ ] aching no I picked up
your cleaner he lost me help me attend
to a certain matter what do you say you
can hear giggling under the hood
all right no I would interest you when
we get there you need to prove that you
can do the job no time witless made you
follow show me what you're made of get
through it to this sound forest think
it's oozing through you prepare myself
before setting out when you get there
you find me in this spot remember it the
world cries what happens couple
something on it
trade I need a [ __ ] shovel [ __ ]
hand gun egg
anything here whatever here you want a
flare baby
gossip but getting a choker you meet at
least to get decent weapon beautify a
perfect sort of road what's he got there
well snatches snorts sure it doesn't
exist through the ground okay
we wish a more quality time Baskin
striking it featured for your head off
you'll find me on cam in the dry meadow
[ __ ] barely made it
nothing I cook
is that my [ __ ] health
okay oh that's where the wolf camp is I
got to get a [ __ ] shovel so I'm just
going straight for the wolf camp
[ __ ] a whoa-ho paint a scrap-metal
[ __ ] I got jumping [ __ ] off now wait -
its [ __ ] here container [ __ ] know the
password
okay okay that's me hmm it's kind of mad
all I don't need right now you probably
make bandages right perfect perfect
don't need this don't need gasoline
right here
I need another wire rope nail okay I
think that's good let's do this [ __ ]
so I'm just save it okay
I think they just to go off the trail
Hawaii there now you know not just let's
have a passenger kinda like it's open
though it's just safer okay so how they
caught the char meadow their dogs the
left a lot of [ __ ] traps around here
did
[ __ ] is that we're getting beat up over
there what are ya
okay
what can I do yeah fine how's that show
item [ __ ] did you can't [ __ ] sucks
sorry dude like that's a true
what I'm for the shinies town what does
that do
steady I need a plank a what dad you got
any of that glare gasoline now tape
watch ooh
I'd like that I'd like that
hmm we said 180 [ __ ] 300 yeah you
know I cut [ __ ] yourself okay
go [ __ ] yourself okay that's it around
here anything to be honest I don't know
if I'd make another name
damn in-n-out
don't forget that okay ah [ __ ]
I didn't say I'd say that [ __ ] sick
as a dog now
AB SEC
what is that
and then over here
I'm in the brach
is that chair
where it says
holy [ __ ] how do I get over there
save me somewhere over here haze barking
oh [ __ ]
never [ __ ] I get out of here where is
that [ __ ] [ __ ] they're gonna fight
our way out muchachos yeah that's
amazing
yeah we just are [ __ ] heading back
where is it
I'd say hey [ __ ] underground entrance
I guess that's it right there
wait is this my house or just undergone
entrance holy [ __ ]
oh yeah [ __ ] this
anything in here
there's barricade yeah
do we do this
[ __ ]
never been inventory okay let's get the
[ __ ] out of here cuz I gotta barricade
this [ __ ] Oh more logs outside
[ __ ] yeah
let's hit the [ __ ] back to the house
okay let me just say
perfect well
confirm
she's a negative
now I don't want to do this now [ __ ]
or with nails ooh that's a good one
change happen
wait can i repair this yet to any
[ __ ] for
emily's can I [ __ ] make you know what
I guess
we shake a lot of scrap metal
mmm-hmm I sound talking about bad bang
so I got my change camp there
it's barricaded
looking at dark I know oh [ __ ]
perfect
well that's if I don't really need right
now like this you can take that scrap
metal button house I really don't need
this shiny stone another bottle hey
that's even
come on come on come on come on [ __ ]
getting dark very fast okay
okay perfect
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] any internal generator
[ __ ] getting dark fast [ __ ] my deck
[ __ ] my deck
okay I think we're pretty good anymore
change wraps no all right we're good
we're good
well I got all right now we just wait I
guess now we just wait can I save I
guess I guess I could save
I like that we're gonna adapt but we're
gonna do my tacos
why isn't this on [ __ ] I guess that one
was on
hey this is where every last holy
[ __ ] uptick chants getting dark very
fast I feel ill prepared [ __ ] by gonna
show oh yeah it's definitely dark down
garand you had huh yeah them
I can pawn your light in here
[ __ ] scaring yeah that [ __ ] eat in
here
I really got [ __ ] up by that one thing
benders it out now I got why siren no
one in here
I said go away sir this house has taken
I said this house is taken I think this
house is take it get out of here
scram scram are you so [ __ ] up in the
dirt there should be a lock outside
though it's how do you make that or
there is no lock [ __ ] where there's a
store were blocking the door I think
yeah down at the light not the generator
I'm interested if they turn on that
thing
if they go through the door I want to
see what what it's like when I change
out well you see that oh there's a guy
out there what's up I'm looking the
shadows they close the light yes I so
please don't turn off mr. lamp
holy [ __ ] it was like [ __ ] ghosts
around here holy [ __ ] they turn off that
light
is it that time that breaking into over
the front door oh [ __ ] someone gets
chained up
not that one was it
and I like that it's not actually a door
there someone's chained up it might be
that one over there by looked like they
say it yeah I'm gonna chow
so I can get a dark again
[ __ ] woof hey just sucking it doesn't
give two shits it just camped out on the
ground [ __ ] bad-ass
and who is that stop that pay a lot of
money for this jar wall
whenever like [ __ ] gasoline exiting
basically me it
Shh
okay
there is that
I take a daylight again oh [ __ ] I saw
through the window if I guess yeah get
the [ __ ] out of here
saving hello sorry miss konstanz guy I
overheard my sighs barely making the
trip and figure as hell - cover with an
old sack Peter call the part I remember
him he's the one who rescued me from the
doctors house are you serious
he reached out to me with his black hand
is covered in charcoal there's something
written just get there brother his lift
your mood paintball hunter on downside
the helmet he shrugs takes echoes
backdrops we her feelings content-item
Alworth lead a bar in the woods okay I
tried
holy [ __ ] this guy got a lot of muchacho
I need this watch that parts so what is
it good I need [ __ ] planks of wood oh
yeah no shucks yeah [ __ ] yeah ok any a
lot of [ __ ] from this guy
[ __ ]
disarm and turn off the [ __ ] generator
before this [ __ ] gets crazy I need that
[ __ ] gas
I need a [ __ ] watch don't you catch
me out of here
just grow back no need two more planks
of one it's fine you see what's out here
anything good [ __ ] hey guys do that [ __ ]
and they got through that check okay we
got ass a little bit with this guy
that's like an edge and I really don't
need this mate for these bottles
a Spanish older it's right the shadow
stamp oh yeah tell state hundred
torch
flashlight right where does the other
watch it that I just saw it and you
doesn't have a watch I'm gonna crazy you
guys [ __ ] handgun for him Jesus there
to stay hundred can I make it there
well yeah okay dad is dope now you're
[ __ ] barricade all the [ __ ] that's
already barricaded so what we'll take
the barricade this need three
hmm what the [ __ ] is the best room ID me
that shovel thing now
[ __ ] he's serious bro ah you [ __ ]
serious
why do you think so expensive I'm set my
handgun for him am I gonna get that
[ __ ] handgun for him
okay do you want this fifth date
get the [ __ ] watch
you know you just kind of keep it in
there okay [ __ ] I need that [ __ ]
weapon anything else you can give me
that take a weapon match [ __ ] axe
[ __ ] gasoline I can't even get that from
him
I'm gonna need that pink okay what can i
connect wet bare with nails
that's my weapon [ __ ] yeah
make a couple chains
[Music]
I prayed items hotbar [ __ ]
sir well you do you want to hear this
[ __ ]
now go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah I gotta be [ __ ] me
alright well [ __ ] it okay I'm gonna save
this well in this episode hand I'll
continue the next one yeah I sold
together in chapters I don't know yet
we'll find out all right have a good one
right ChaCha's have a good one